la crisis en Darwin Street genera ondas
de choque a nivel global los líderes de
los países más cercanos fueron los
primeros en pronunciarse creo que lo
importante como vecino más cercano de
Reino Unido es que tenemos una relación
económica significativa y muchas otras
relaciones más la estabilidad es lo más
importante Nos gustaría ver que el
sistema de Reino Unido esté dentro de la
capacidad para estar en posesión de
tener un sucesor lo más rápido posible y
que traiga estabilidad a la situación
tuve un buen contacto con ella
coincidimos en toda serie de puntos de
vista y Estoy ansioso por ver con quién
trabajaré será de quinto creo los
líderes de las principales potencias
occidentales desean una sola cosa para
Reino Unido estabilidad quiero decir que
Francia como amigo del pueblo británico
espera la estabilidad de Reino Unido y
en el contexto de la guerra y tensiones
por la crisis energética es importante
que Reino Unido vuelva a emprender el
camino de la estabilidad política a
nivel personal siempre me entristece ver
partir a un colega
Estados Unidos y el Reino Unido son
fuertes aliados y amigos duraderos y ese
hecho nunca cambiará agradezco a la
primera ministra listros por su
colaboración en una variedad de temas
incluidas las exigencias de
responsabilidades a Rusia por su guerra
contra Ucrania continuaremos nuestra
estrecha cooperación con el gobierno del
Reino Unido mientras trabajamos juntos
para enfrentar los desafíos globales los
comentarios de burla A su corta
administración llegaron desde Rusia el
premio Nobel de economía por la
destrucción más rápida del sistema
financiero nacional Debería ser otorgado
a Trust Reino Unido nunca ha conocido
una desgracia igual en un Primer
Ministro duró 45 días en el cargo y
renunció tan solo un día después de
decir que era una luchadora y no una
desertora